hey guys welcome back to brand-new vid
today's Thursday instead to recap
they're back on for negai hopefully you
guys had a good 4th of July if you do
celebrate that I know I did and with
that we're gonna be recapping the
definition that happened today and we
have some interesting news about a July
roadmap and stuff like that what's
coming in the future for for honor for
the next couple months as well as a
summer sale the tech test in a new emote
which is really nice I can't wait to
show you guys let's get into that as
always I cover the informational side of
foreigner that being balanced James's
hero updated leaks new events all the
patch notes and all that good stuff so
like I said let's get started with
today's video
so first up this show of a roadmap for
July and early August about stuff coming
to for on her in the future and to start
off and to recap most of it there will
be a summer sale from July 12th to the
19th and we'll get into that a little
bit later in the video what that is once
the summer sale is over there'll be a
realistic Dominion which will make a
return from July 19th to July 26th and
then the day after I'm July 27th when
season six comes to a close and season 7
will start up after the off season in
August 2nd and then there will be an
extra boo fest following the day after
season 7 starts on August the 3rd season
7 most likely come with the warden and
the Valkyrie ryx we've talked about for
the past couple weeks and they will most
likely show a gameplay of what they had
so stay tuned so you could hear all
about it as I will gladly recap for you
guys and keep you up-to-date with all
the latest news about these new reworks
coming the new content of the week is a
hero based emote called kill card which
is very innovative and he chose her
shield emblem on the card when you throw
it on the floor and it appears from the
black smoke as well which is awesome
because that never existed before and I
sped this video up a shit-ton because
this is like a four-minute video and I
didn't want to bore you
so I sped it up a bit so everyone can
see what all those look like and those
would be costing 7000 steal each next up
were just a few quick bits of info that
being the tech test for the new hero's
Qi on D and Shaolin as well as the
breach mode are out today so if he did
get into the tech that's definitely go
try that stuff out and report it to the
devs I sadly did not get a copy but I
heard a couple of you guys in the
comment section did so it's really
awesome can't wait to see what's going
on sadly though is an NDA so I won't
cover they post about it but I'm just
glad that a lot of people are at least
able to test this so that the characters
can be hopefully spotless when they come
into the actual game
and on top of that dance a death is also
odd now and to pair that up the new
event order is going to be the first
faction to have the most wins in brawl
will win a nice reward of steel which is
really nice about dance of death
if you are new dance of death is this
one mode that they added to quite
recently and probably a season or two
ago which doesn't sound that recent but
to me it is basically dance of death is
just normal brawl but you have to kill
the opposing team at the same time and
once they die they respawn and it their
timer starts from two seconds of a
respawn to three to four to five all the
way up to probably infinity I have never
even gotten that far and my game to
think the most I've ever gotten was ten
so these can go pretty long games or
they gonna be really short depending on
how well you communicate with your team
but the Pope both of the opposing
members have to be dead on the enemy
team for you to win the round and now
we're gonna get into what the summer
shows which I talked about earlier in
the video and basically just about
everything is 50% off so if there's any
emotes executions effects or masks that
you wanted to give me you couldn't
because of the cost you'll most likely
be able to afford it now this would be
going on from July 12th to July 19th
also if you have older equipment like
older season one and two ornaments and
stuff like that you may be in luck
because your stuff might be considered
rare for a bit one issue is when a new
player comes into the game there's so
much stuff in the game and it could be
overwhelming on what to choose so they
decide to remove some old items in the
game for a bit if you currently have one
of these items or anything like that in
your inventory or in on your character
they won't delete it from there if you
already have it but if you don't have it
it will most likely be gone and you
won't be able to buy it I'm assuming on
this exact release date they didn't
really give a set release date and when
this is going to happen but it's
supposed to be on a cycle so for example
for two months any stuff released in
season one or two will be gone from the
shop but maybe two months later those
emotes effects etc will come back in the
shop but now it's the season 3 Cosmetics
will disappear for a time once again
this is not 100% positive this is just
an example just to show you what they
mean by that and like I said they're
doing this because of the amount of
cosmetics this game has and they just
wanted the lessen the load a little bit
and to end the video we have what I'm
going to start doing a lot more now our
question of the week and that is since
season six is coming to a close what was
your opinion on this season in general
did you enjoy it was it boring or just
another season in the book tell me why
in the comments below I'd love to know
your thoughts and I'll most likely be
responding to all these comments as well
since I love starting a discussion with
you personally for me I thought season
six was just a little bit boring because
there were there wasn't too much we did
have the event in the beginning which
was within us but it was a bit
lackluster for me personally because I
don't play a row team peacekeepers or
the reworks I don't really give a [ __ ]
about when you might have cared a lot I
like I said I'd loved so many thoughts
in the comments below and with that
that's going to be the end of the video
today guys hopefully guys didn't enjoy
if the emo video is still going in the
background I'm just gonna let that go to
the end of the video I have no clue how
long it'll be maybe it's already done
I'm not entirely sure though but I like
the view if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new I cover the informational
side of foreign I like to keep everybody
up to date with all the latest news on
foreign and that being balanced changes
here or updates new reworks new events
new seasonal stuff all that type of
stuff like the cover here on the channel
my two most recent videos will be on the
screen if you guys want to check that
out when that guys over regret yesterday
and thank you for watching the video and
peace out